okay you ready okay my name is Dave
Achilles I'm a clinical allergists I
also work in the lab in Australia this
talk is really going to be my personal
view as to how the newer technologies
analogy fit into the clinical it will be
a bit of a historical food court in
terms of what we're we're up to and then
how the component resolve diagnosis
gnostics built upon this this this this
these historical improvements it's also
going to sort emphasize the both the
promise and also limitations of this
technology particularly in terms of
clinical diagnosis it's called the
allergy older and you and I'm sorry for
some of you who already knew know this
very well but I think I have to get some
background and some sort of clinical
background first and then build upon
this sort of clinical background to see
where these are these techniques within
you now there's no webcam because
unfortunately the internet connections
were such that i took that all up all
over the place and i'm a bit of a turkey
person anyway and this was that this was
beyond a joke when I when they was
joking this on i'm gerry penis so we all
know the mechanisms of allergy we know
that what we're talking about in terms
of allergy is argue mediate disease and
we all know that i do to allergen
cross-links receptors on Marcel's that
leads to the allergic response at least
in Australia the the physicians we're
looking at our two principal diseases
one is in fact a topic related disease
at the next big area that we look
in Australia is anaphylaxis and also we
have this sort of pseudo allergy which
is a sort of I've non ige-mediated
allergy involving marvels but the
mechanisms of which are slightly unclear
now the big area of two areas are ideal
within clinical practice analogy is
firstly clinically ige-mediated Aziz
rhinitis asthma and eczema and there is
plenty of evidence that there is
sensitization here with specific ige
positive in these diseases and testing
and specific ID in serum and essentially
as well as the sort of clinical aspects
of this there is also the family history
aspect of evasive clean so that's one
big group that I deal with and we all
know that atopic disease is increasing
and all of it is increasing and
increasing in a sequential fashion there
was an increase of a sermon asthma death
to start off with there's no an increase
of rhinitis and excellent and also an
increase of being particular food
allergy the big the other big area i
deal with clinically is the severe
life-threatening reaction of anaphylaxis
this is separate because it can occur in
narcotic individuals and essentially
except for food and up Laxus frequently
it occurs in non a type of individuals
and essentially the the clinical aspects
of business food medication and insect
Venom's and we have a fair bit of insect
venom anaphylaxis here and I understand
in the in in the United States very
similar in terms of wassman be a
medication is important because people
tend to occur in older group and there's
a bigger death rate of this and also
there's food anaphylaxis now the the
with what what I think I need to
emphasize in this business of allergy
is that is the moving fit essentially we
have them and what we can say is in
terms of anaphylaxis this is quite quite
common in terms of the fact that we used
to have peanut anaphylaxis and this has
vastly increased in the last 20 years in
our saline cohorts it's double what it
was 15 20 years ago but also we get
Mueller aspects of different allergens
coming on board and this is depends upon
the increase of consumption so
essentially we had peanut increasing
more recently we've had attached to nuts
and now we've had Brazil nut and this is
really related to overall wheel
consumption and also the price of these
maps in terms of the lending use
widespread lean in infants likewise we
used to see a lot of penicillin
anaphylaxis but now all the studies
across the world would say that Kepler
sporrans have superseded penicillins as
a cause of anaphylaxis and then of
course because they're we only prawns
rather than fish now for another flex is
increasing and once again although latex
and flexes wasn't wasn't important cause
a couple of years ago now for texting is
more kind so essentially the first thing
I want to say is is that the allergens
of today are going to be different from
the allergens of 20 years ago and crop
that's the allergens in the future and
and it has to be borne in mind now why
do we do allergy testing the list two
reasons firstly we have to say is
allergy causing the clinical problem and
what allergen is causing the clinical
problem and the second question is that
is the most common question which
patient is asked and as essentially
there's a lot of different ways in which
we can prove or disprove that allergy is
causing the problem and the historical
histories is the key and in terms of the
Association of maps allergen with
clinical symptoms and that's really
important to emphasize that we aren't
doing testing in the vacuum which is
we're doing test testing in the context
of clinical history and then we I don't
have to tell an audience like this the
skin testing has been around for a long
time then there's specific guides used
to allergen and then there's challenge
with allergen with a goddess which is a
gold standard for foods and also with
response to in North era p so there's a
large range of things causing the
problem now traditionally skin testing
has been the what's what we've used for
allergy testing and this has been
associated with history positive skin
test and preceded by specific ig2 to
allergens and the common allergens we
have in Australia our couch and hash
dust mite and B and rye grass now
originally what happened is that
specific igg to allergen was a secondary
test to skin testing when our skin
Twitter was unavailable when there was
interfering medications or eczema and
also with young children and durmitor
graphism and anaphylaxis so originally
skin testing was the gold standard and
specific ige elegant was it was it was a
secondary test and I have to emphasize
this because this is this explains the
history of the improvements in specific
ige to allergen which was sort of done
in this clinical context where people to
the history they did skin testing and
then it was it was felt that in fact
that with these indications this course
which would be tested specific I g22 to
allergens and once again the CM testing
originally was was this some proprietary
named rass testing and in more recently
you know that bad yet Siemens are a
whole range of other manufacturers have
produced improvements are on this
testing
the the actual sort of principles of
this test we haven't really changed that
from that much as and as the audience
knows that you've got a solid food
allergen you add the theorem which
contains of specific antibodies you
separate out the bound from the free and
you add a labelled an anti ngige and
this is sort of my very very crude
interpretation you get the allergen in
the solid phase you add the theorem and
you add the anti-ige now this is this is
what I what this is my main method
message that a lot of the improvements
to start off with in the last like 10 or
15 years have been to do to improve the
sensitivity of the SFA to pick up stuff
that skin type thing kicks up but the in
vitro assay doesn't pick up and that's
been for over long period of time what
the most recent improvements have been
in fact to improve lack of specificity
and this is the bugbear of clinical
allergy you have a lot of people with
positive tests but do not actually have
the allergy when in contact with the
allergen and and this is the second
phase which we've been trying to
encounter get that improve and this'll
be in the lack of specificity and so I
want to sort of go through a lack of
sensitivity because and how this has
been sort of addressed because this will
ties in with the second phase of
improvements of lack of specificity and
and essentially the pub the requirements
for good clinical practice in my own
mind that firstly the test has to be as
good as in testing but secondly the high
specificity because what you need to do
is you need to test and you need to say
look that if if the post if that test is
positive then if I challenge that person
with the allergen then the person will
so high specificity is important
preferred because you really want to
sort of sight test it safe and say well
if you're negative for that text you
won't we actually food allergen if
you're positive to the TAC test you will
react for food allergen and there's a
quite a high bar in terms of clinical
testing because you you really want to
make sure because you can't go around
sort of giving foods to these people and
then reacting or in fact making sure
restricting their diets for no reason so
you need a very good test and so
specific is very important and also high
specificity is very good important in
terms of arrow a collagen in the therapy
because you're going to subject them to
sort of 4 3 2 for 25 years of perhaps
injections or sublingual drops on the
basis of the testing so high sensitivity
is important in terms of the fact that s
have to be as good as in testing but
high specificity is very important in
terms you're dealing with sort of
reactions to thurs you might have to
make sure that the that the tips
completely rules out and complete
relative if possible reactions and also
with the eminent therapy as well so i
just wanted to sort of put that down as
a sort of clinical so feeling so the
only one and I'll just whisk through
this was firstly to make the Rastas
sense to the skin testing and this was
done by a range of manufacture anxiety
I've used the proprietary rest phrase
again and the first thing was to
increase the sensitivity by increase the
allergen band in the solid phase and
this is this was based on the fact that
if you put enough allergen on the solid
phase then you would suck up right this
picky bit ban does with the sugar and
everything else is you would suck up all
the antibodies in the serum and
therefore the binding would not be
affinity that
would be affinity independent and
therefore you have all the specific igg
SAT up onto the disk and therefore you'd
be able to measure all the I IGS
tactical allergen and that had and so it
was as good as skin testing in terms of
sensitivity so that was the first thing
and this was done by a large range of
different systems and I'm sorry and
thaddeus allowed me to use this slide
but there were other systems and I just
happened to have these around so
essentially a number of systems were
made and one of them was the inner cap
which had a lot more sort of area bound
for the allergen to bind and therefore
that was able to stack up a lot more ID
and if it was able to increase the
sensitivity of the essay and it was
claimed and I think there was some
evidence that there was enough energy
sucked up and comparison of the total
itu could do parallel curves and this
was that this led to the the important
thing and a london number of the
manufactures have done the same thing in
terms of you to convert a qualitative
test to a quantitative test so the first
thing firstly there was increased
sensitivity but secondly you could
increase you could increase it to an
extent that you can now in fact do
parallel curves with total ID and and
and lead to a quantitative test and and
this is in fact improves things and
essentially also you could do quality
control testing and you could get
reproducibility between lamps and we
have the locally we have our art our CPA
external quality control and stuff like
that now having said that the second
phase has been to improve the
specificity of allergy testing and I
want to sort of spend the rest of the
talk about this and this has been a real
back there and this is a work in
progress and I think will be a work in
progress for a long time and none of the
improvements I'll just underline this
none of the improvements recently have
improved specificity of allergy testing
sufficiently for us to be comfortable in
a clinical sense they had it improved
its somewhat but it's not like the
improvements of sensitivity which have
been remarkable and very good but
improvements and specificity have just
not quite got there and I'll take you
through this for the rest of the talk
essentially the causes for low
specificity are numerous but that
essentially what's happened is you know
you can be sensitized to a particular
allergen but once that doesn't really
mean when you're in contact with the
halogen you're actually going to react
or you have clinical allergy you may
have sensitivities specific guide you to
a luncheon but essentially a lot of
people have specific I do to to food and
yet when they take that particular food
they're fine and this is related to the
type of antibody affinity or prime
specificity or specific activity of the
antibody itself so that that the
antibody itself doesn't lead to the
reaction but also I have to emphasize
there's a lot of non ige-mediated
factors that interfere that interfering
idg there's problems with the sort of
Marcel and Howard react reacts to the
specific IG and also there's how the
histamine impacts on on on the on on the
vessels and and the immune mediators etc
like that so so the association between
cancellation and clinical allergy is
very complex and therefore just altering
a test to make it better doesn't
necessarily improve specificity and I
think we have to emphasize that and I
will concentrate on on food allergy
because this is where a lot of the
attempts of improving specificity have
gone into and where it's quite
remarkable how what people have done
that once again hadn't led to reveal an
end-all of solving all these problems so
in terms of amazing specificity for food
allergen what we have done what
have been done repent occasions if you
measure a level of specific ideas of
food so now you've got a quantitative
test for ID you can actually have a
level and then you challenge with the
food under controlled conditions and
then you record whether or not the food
people react in a standardized way and
you compare the level of specific igg to
the probability of reaction to food and
this is being made possible because of
both improvements in the clinical area
and the lab area and I wish to emphasize
that the there's been improved fast
improvement of food challenge protocols
and reproducible food challenge pretzels
which without that we wouldn't be able
to look at the in vitro testing in
comparison there's been reproduced
improvements of reproducible of
assessment of reactions to foods in
terms of the clinical arena but also
there has been the ability to quantitate
specific ID measurements so all these
three improvements in clinical and lab
factors has led to ability to look at
specificity and a lot more scientific
fashion and this was sort of that arose
from sort of Samson's working in in the
early early and nineties last century so
I'm a little bit behind still and
essentially what they did is they did
they may it rest in killer units of
antibody per liter and then they looked
at the IG antibody concentrations for
egg cleanup milk and fish and as has
been done on numerous occasions they
looked at the levels of pub which there
was a ninety-five percent success 454
critical allergy in other words there's
a specificity of ninety-five percent
above which you get clinical allergy
that doesn't mean that knife right sent
from people react because that's
obviously the positive predictive value
but at least there's fifty of
ninety-five percent above which you know
they're above which there is this
specificity and clinical allergy is
defined
of the chances to to food so so this is
the sort of graphs we have on numerous
occasions we have a probability and an
ekat rest we have a certain level of
publish there's no five percent
probability of reacting remember in
clinical allergy obviously it depends
upon how when we are in terms of
diagnosing people so if we if we would
take a whole population and screen them
we still would have a pool or posted
predictive value for ninety five percent
festiva see as you know so that this
only works if we've got to compete with
Brooklyn or histories and then we take
95 cents specificity so so so this is
great so you have a cut-off above which
there's no pipe synthesis is the full or
reacting to that first and and and
actually have in clinical allergy the
trouble is is if you look at look at the
people who have our causes the hell have
cut below these cut-offs you still have
a large number of people who will still
react to the food in other words you
know it's fine if you're above this
cutter but if you're below this cutter
you may still react to that food and in
fact fifty percent of patients in the
peanut our literature with positive
challenges still who are below the
cutoff are below the cutoff and have had
positive challenge and so what happens
is if your life I've Senate and you're
above the cutoff above that 95 10 Cubs
you're fine but if you below the cutoff
then you still have to challenge and
that may be up to 50 cent off operations
and the other problem with this is you
know you really want to know who's going
to get anaphylaxis if challenged and the
strength of the
reactivity with our G's does not predict
this and this is another problem and the
next problem is as I alluded to before
if you take a sort of low prevalence
population if you scream then you're
less likely to have a critical allergy
in that you're above the code so what's
everything if you don't have the right
the right population error legends I'm
not going to go into but with this cut
off principle yes it's sort of work
specific ige levels correlate with
inhalation challenge to technology might
specific ige does correlate with the
concentration however the it's not
perfect and also we're bummed by the
lack of well-documented and easy to do
clinical measurements of reactions to
the cat or has customized okay so let's
get get get get through to the topic in
light line and I wanted to give that
very long the introduction because you
know i think is impossible to sort
understand this area without actually
having having having this its
introduction so what next in specificity
component resolved diagnosis and and I
unassailably and going to do a polar the
fattiest slide to point the rosy picture
and then I'm going to sort of go back
and say well it isn't really that much
Rosie and Guardian once again has a loud
mixer or their local rep abacus has
allowed me to use these slides and it's
some slides I just got out because I
thought well let's put the rosy picture
and then and then sort of slightly
demolish it so essentially you know as
you know able to contain thousands of
molecules and this won't take long of
which only a few are allergenic and so
you know you can actually extract
obviously specific allergen components
from the allergen itself and you can
distinguish
in specific allergy and components to a
whole lot of components which are cross
reactive and the assumption is is the
important are important ideas the ideas
for specific components so essentially
if you have an ology to across the
active component whether it occurs in
other foods and stuff like that it's
less important and I'll discuss that
later and also if the ideas to a stable
allergens and that's important and will
more critical and essentially obviously
if the idea too is is to is to a
component which is which is quite
plentiful in the food then it's more
important so you sort of build up a sort
of i sort of absolute priority list of
ID's where i use specific is the most
important of course the reactions to
cross reactive is less likely and two
more label our products is less likely
so I'd uses specific is genuine
sensitization so they take era h2 and
and gal v1 as an example cross-reactive
not so important because obviously
reacting to cross reactive food so
presumably less important if it's labile
it's less important but if it's not
Jesus table it's important and you know
they build up a list of protein so
fulfilling obviously as a protein which
is a bit more labile so brakes done in
the stomach and if it's less likely to
be important and whereas lipids transfer
proteins and storage proteins they're
much more stable protein so IG against
these sets of proteins is much more
important and so increase risk of
reaction and this is this is very much
likely the labels protein is less likely
to get to the stomach in for systemic
reaction where the stable protein is
much more likely to get to the stomach
and cause a systemic reaction and this
is exemplified in their will in their
thing which is
which is quite good in terms of sort of
message that have had problems I think
in terms of being a little bit too too
optimistic our age two and one free our
storage proteins so they're stable
they're in high amounts they are more
specific slightly more specific and so
these are likely to be the problems in
peanut for felonies and low amounts it's
unstable and therefore it's less likely
to be a problem in peanut our age 2 is
in lower months and therefore it's less
likely be important and once again our
age 9 is in low and mine so less likely
to be importance and so what you see is
you by testing get individual containers
of allergens you can assess clinical
risk explain symptoms due to cross
reactivity and you can identify the
specific immunotherapy and so this is a
sort of thing you have Emma who has a
local reaction to peanut who has a both
have local reactions of peanuts emma has
antibodies against our age two and three
and therefore you're really worried
about her whereas Carolyn there's also
the same age like reaction to peanuts
has it has antibodies against Raj and
therefore this is a cross reactive and
antigen and therefore that you don't
have to worry so the theory goes okay
now I'd like to say that yes there is
some evidence that component resolved
diagnostics like this works as in as in
these lives but in some ways what
happens is this techniques that have
come on board it's brilliant technology
in that we can sort of do recombinant
and sends and stuff like that but it's
more of a technique that's been looking
for a use and it has a use in terms of
what they say but it's a little bit
complex and translating into a clinical
scenario and clinical use is live a
little bit more difficult now I'll just
go back to the sorts of what would what
we want to do we want a more specific
antibody ID antibody and we want it more
specific than the specific idea to hold
antigen so we've got skin testing we've
got specific ID idaho lance in now if we
want to improve on it we really need to
improve it in some specificity and what
we mean by this is that that the ID has
to have a better correlation with
qualitative challenge in terms of food
allergy and what this means harking back
to what we've done before is we all know
that if we can get a cut off with 95
above which there's nine five percent
specificity that's fine and we can do
that for both the newer technology or
the older technology however the
probability older technology is we've
still got this large portion of people
who still react below the cutoff so as I
mentioned in peanut allergy fifty
percent of our people react who are the
other who reacted to peanut are below
this car off and so the whole point of
having these newer technologies should
be to actually reduce these number of
patients who actually are reacting and
who are below the cutoff and if possible
a better technique would be those that
that's better correlate the severity of
reaction we're not going to get it get
over this problem if we have a if we
people start screening whole populations
with these antibodies no test is going
to help because essentially the
prevalence of that of the conditions to
live so all these testing are sort of
depend upon the fact that people have to
have tests in the inappropriate
population so what this is the sorts of
bottom line and what I'm saying is and
and I just want if you can hold on there
and I see the sum of the attendance
tender these have left already but I
just want to sort of if you're going to
just sort of hang on for another five
minutes because this this is a little
bottom line this is the example of ID to
era h2 which is a component to write
aspect molecule from peanut and what
it's shown in this study in the touch
study is that if you're if you actually
try to get this 90 91 or ninety five
percent cut off and use our h2 then then
what's happened in is that the error h2
yes you know you can get 95 cents
specificity and it improves the
sensitivity below the cut up in other
words that the ability to pick up people
who react be below the cut this cut off
those those sort of up from safe above
discount seventy percent of people who
have above this color will react and
only thirty percent of reactors will be
below the cutoff so so the bottom line
is this component arrived testing
what it does is it reduces the number of
people who will react below the car off
but it doesn't reduce it completely so
in normal using specific ID to fold
allergen 495 sent to cover a specificity
you'll get about fifty percent you'll
pick up fifty percent of reactors what
the component derived testing will do is
full a ninety-five percent cut off it
will reduce this figure to about thirty
to them so you'll still have people who
are you react below the cover but it'll
be lesser the trouble is what you need
clinically is down to ten or five
percent you really need to reduce that
figure who will react below that carbon
for it to be useful so it sort of helps
but it doesn't complete but doesn't
completely eliminate those people who
will react and are going to be below the
cutoff if I'm with you and you can ask
questions if you don't understand it and
essentially all these sort of all these
or next couple of slides say exactly the
same thing so so if the guys are sort of
take the ninety five percent cut off 95
cents specificity so this is a ROC curve
and we take them ninety-five percent
specificity and we say well you know if
if is no five cents specificity how much
of the of the reactors we don't a sort
of pick up in this ninety-five percent
above 95 cents specificity and it's
about 75% in other words we still have
twenty five percent below that collar
for still going to react and this is the
Australian study which was done a couple
of years ago and once again very similar
things if we take the knife I sense
there's a 50 which is here we will still
for the arrow h2 still have about twenty
or thirty percent below this cut off
which will still react however will pick
eighty percent this is a lot better than
than most other modalities it's sort of
multivalent I think there's a lot better
than the specific I'd use a whole thing
up but it still had this problem in that
even if we take you know if we even if
we have a cut off above which is nice
I've said chance of reacting then we
still have this group this irritating
group of patients not if they're not
irritating but it's problematic group of
patients were below the cutoff who still
react so it doesn't prevent us we still
have to challenge patients whether or
not they're above weather with if
they're below the cutoff because we
don't know whether they're not in this
residual fruit same thing with egg and
milk in that if we look at the night
lights and specificity we still have
this seventy or eighty percent
sensitivity with Boston Tea eighth week
who will react to but will be picked up
in 95 test but still we have this twenty
percent who will still react and are
below this cutoff and once again with
global v1 for a once again if is a is if
we take no content specificity then we
still have twenty percent who of
reactors who will be below this cutoff
so essentially it's improved matters but
it hasn't to improvement sufficiently
for us that the users as a standalone
test and it definitely hasn't improved
matters in terms of the fact that we
just do the test and not worry about the
patient and so you can have peanut
because you know even for the lower cut
if you're below the cut-offs you still
have you still may be there in the
twenty percent whoo-hoo actually
reactive foods so I just want to
emphasize this component derived that
diagnostics result i also have improved
the situation but
is sufficiently for it to stop us from
challenging people if we feel they need
to be challenged and do similar to other
not to other nuts one thing which is a
bit boring also about the complainant
drive diagnostics is the cutoff switch
we're looking at maybe a specific and
also geographical specifically adaptable
specifically specificity and also that
performance might be a lot worse if if
there is another a so for instance is
enough staff study if we look at the
ninety-five percent specificity here for
Cara a 14 and hazelnut components then
this only has a thirty-one percent
sensitivity in other words seventy
percent of people will will still react
if below the cutoff and once again also
this is a this is very similar in terms
of the the other allergen if we look at
the 95 cents and specificity again the
sensitivity is low so just going on
these studies are a little bit of a
worry because the studies may only apply
for a selected AIDS and maybe different
cut-offs of different ages there's a
feeling that even in clean up the
geographical area might be important the
the if we take community-based studies
then the performance might be a lack of
a lot lesser because all these studies
are predicated some of them are
predicated on the fact that these people
cost of skin test so peanut already and
we really don't know that the analytical
performance of these components at the
95 cents cut off so bottom line is that
things have been proved but they haven't
been improved sufficiently to stop us
for
challenging people refers ok so what why
is this a problem essentially there's a
lot of lot of problems the component
resolve Diagnostics there's a relevant
molecules they might be cross reactive
allergens we've got a tertiary structure
and some allocations maybe just sort of
representation of how much we can get
and purify them there may be variation
between individuals and then maybe post
translational modifications columns very
early stages called some of the
components resolved diagnostics do pick
up things that be that the other the
traditional testing doesn't but the
problem is we really don't know how
clinically relevant these things are for
instance this is a pollen study and it
demonstrates the component resolve
Diagnostics pick up a lot more olive to
all of allergy than the others but it's
very difficult to know the components of
older of oral role of allergy as opposed
to cross reactive grass allergy and
whether or not it if they're there
they're relevant and I think its early
stages there some people are now looking
and this isn't a nice study proposing a
sort of schedule for even a therapy
depend upon component result Diagnostics
but once again this is that this is
problematic because it doesn't prove
whether or not selecting in the therapy
on Ernest basis of these component
resolve diagnosis there is any better
than just selecting in on terms of skin
testing or a specific ite testing and
and and the complex studies are needed
in order to sort of validate these sorts
of sorts of things okay now I'll a very
briefly look at microarray technology
and as you know this is where you have a
lot of different allergens ownership and
it feeds on from components arrive
the law of diagnostics in terms of the
faculty each component is a little
little tip and so you get some hundreds
and hundreds of different allergens and
this is a real problem in that it's very
early stages and but it looks promising
in that this is a study on on latex
allergy and you can see where the true
positives will will sort come up with
certain components whether the false
positives will come up with with other
components I went to one of them even
though small amounts of theorem can be
used with this and and there's
replicates and get replicates the basic
problem with microwave is we're back
we're back to the future in that the Mac
amount of allergen that can be put on
each ship is limited and therefore the
sensitivity of microarray for these
components is is has not been well
evaluated and you can get interferences
with igg and so once again early days in
terms of clinical uses so in summary I
want to say that there have been great
advances in terms of allergy testing in
terms of in vitro specific ideology
testing that component to write resolve
Diagnostics does offer promise but it
hasn't solved all the problems and I
took food allergy as an example where as
we can it does improve in fact the
resolution of the comparison with
challenge testing but it's not good
enough in terms of clinical practice and
that we still have to
challenge a lot of people particularly
if they're below that cut off and that's
early days with microarray and pollen
and arrow allergen component resolved
diagnostics in that the clinical studies
haven't been done to sufficiently to be
confident of them this is a personal
view that's a personal view based on
allergy practices in Australia and I'll
be happy to take questions any any
questions and so I've gone into q QA and
there is a no questions on display I
wait a couple of wait a minute or two to
see there's any in equations and anybody
wants to wants to put forward what's
your experience is that with component
resolved Diagnostics yes so will you
make your slides available yes no
problems whatsoever you're mainly from
the I'll just click on see where you
come from if that's okay you're mainly
from
the year so so a lot of you are from
from companies that make make allergy
testing and vector allergy testing
equipment and staff fun to do people
watch what's your feeling about
component component resolved Diagnostics
in terms of where it's going any any use
no sir that's fine okay okay so we might
we might sort of hurt Matt why do that
now thank you very much for attending
and I hope you got some some information
on this in terms of the sort of clinical
application of these pills thank you
very much